[Music]
Kiki Palmer basking in the joys of
motherhood you already know check out
the new mama serenading her little one
leodus to Mariah Carey's it's a wrap
[Music]
s
Kiki welcomed her baby boy just over a
week ago with boyfriend Darius Jackson
this has been the biggest blessing fans
might remember her pregnancy reveal back
in December during her SNL debut
shocking fans with a glimpse of her bump
your girl is ready for the park and
since Kiki's been transparent about her
Whirlwind Life as a new mom oh my gosh
come on let's talk about it
[Music]
[Applause]
just days ago she shared insight into
some of the struggles she's faced in her
motherhood Journey so far I just came
over here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape
matter of fact clip off your angel wings
because
I don't know how you think you did it
Kiki paid tribute to single parents
while reflecting on her own experiences
as a first-time mother I really don't
want this to sound like you know pandery
or something like this because I know
there's a million and one reasons why
somebody wants to be a single parent or
has become a single parent maybe they
lost somebody maybe they don't want to
deal with somebody maybe it's a choice
but when it comes to raising a kid I've
already learned in these short few days
that
it takes a village despite it all she's
keeping things real as she navigates
Parenthood you have my respect system
[Music]